this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah it's really fun to be back here Not
only was I an undergrad here I was a
plant science major and so I took the
majority of my undergrad classes in this
building and when I saw plant science
404 I was like I'm sure I've been in
that room and I heard many many seminars
in this so it's really fun to yeah to be
here
um okay
so
for most of my career as you can imagine
being a plant science major in this
department I've been really interested
in host microbe interactions and across
my career I've been really interested in
sort of the Continuum and the spectrum
of host microbe and host pathogen
interactions
um and so symbiosis I Define uh in sort
of its its classical definition which
means living together
um and I'm getting a little cut off at
the bottom there but it includes
pathogens mutualists and commensals um
and so I'm going to use it to mean sort
of all living together interactions
including your mutualistic symbiosis
um but I've been really interested in
how hosts and microbes navigate this
Continuum so to host get to the side the
microbes decide and how when they come
together does that interaction determine
the outcome of this interaction
um and so from my time uh in my PhD work
I learned that these these changes can
actually occur over very short
evolutionary distances and so
agrobacterium
um our plant pathogen and cyanorezobium
um a mutualist are actually very closely
related so in the Box cut off down here
is cyanore rhizobia which is very
closely related to uh to agrobacterium
which is also in the box that's a plant
pathogen and if you make a sentinel plot
of these
I don't know if I can actually pull that
down a little bit no
uh
okay you can see it over there thank you
um let's close down
oh okay
I thank you
um oh yeah on this one there we go too
many computers and screens okay good
um thank you
so if you plot the genomes of
agrobacterium here and cyanorezobium um
you can see that they're actually uh
very highly conserved so each dot is is
a protein coding Gene and you can see
that if you line them up uh they
actually align quite well with a few you
know exceptions
um but over an evolutionary distance
where you can line up genomes you have a
mutualist and a pathogen
um so that suggests that relatively
small genomic changes can drive these
major transitions in Lifestyles between
bacteria
and now I'm not advancing okay
um so I actually my interest in these
sorts of questions started here in this
department uh and uh often in this very
building I actually have used this slide
before I didn't even make it just for
the stock
um
uh and I started working on this very
famous plant pathogen uh late blade
which is a devastating uh you know
pathogen and is about as far from
rhizobia legume and am fungi as you can
get
um
just a brief interlude I actually one of
my first classes that I took in this
department was uh as a freshman my
faculty advisor suggested that I take
Plant Pathology and I went into Bill's
class and the first day everybody was
talking about like our genes and
agrobacterium transformation and I had
no idea what was going on
and I went up to Bill I don't know if
you remember the story I went up to Bill
uh and I was like I don't think I should
be in this class because I have no idea
what's going on and you're like he was
like okay what's your name and I said
Cara Haney and he was like oh you're
Irish you're only here because of a
plant pathogen you should absolutely be
in this class
and so it turns out that that's true and
I had no idea at the time but my own
personal family history was shaped by
plant micro interactions so my dad's
family fled Ireland during the Irish
Potato Famine in the late 1880s and
immigrated uh to North America at that
time and so that I worked in Bill's lab
uh and so on but
um from this you know there's been a few
things that really have stuck with me
the first is that plant microbes have
shaped human history but second within
this pathogen uh a single pathogen so
right I've talked about spectrum of
pathogens having multiple Lifestyles a
single pathogen can have multiple
Lifestyles so uh glycophthora is a case
where they have this biotrophic stage
where they look like they're not even
doing anything to the plants and then
they suddenly kill the plants something
else that uh I often um mention from
this is that you can also have tissue
specificity and I'll come back to that
at the end but with tomatoes and
potatoes and late blight sometimes you
see the fruits are like perfectly
healthy on the tomatoes and the leaves
are dead or the potato tubers will be
completely rotten and the leaves look
healthy so there seems to be uh yeah
something around tissue specificity that
I
um I have sort of kept with me through
my career
um so about the time I graduated I heard
a seminar by a new professor that was
being recruited into the department
Maria Harrison and I suddenly was like
there's this whole other world of plant
pathogens or plant microbe interactions
and so sort of inspired by working on
sort of The Other Extreme I went and
worked with rhizobia legume um symbiosis
and an amazing thing about this system
is that you have uh You Can Do genetics
um in a way that is really difficult
with potatoes more feasible with
tomatoes
um so in this mutualistic interaction
you can screen for mutants that lose the
ability to form nodules uh and that have
lost the nitrogen fixings and biosis
um but here you still have rhizobia in
these nodules and so
um
uh there's a lot of questions that sort
of arose about how does the plant
control this how does the plant avoid
rhizobia becoming a pathogen taking more
nutrients uh then it can afford to share
and then how do plants actually avoid
being parasitized by these microbes uh
and then as I mentioned our pathogens
are mutual is really so different as
these are very closely related to path
um and so that in Sharon's lab I really
started thinking about this Continuum
um and I think it's best exemplified
with these Alpha proteobacteria as I
mentioned where we have cyanorizobium
and agrobacterium as close relatives
um even more amazingly these are more
closely related to each other than they
are to Brady rhizobium which is another
nitrogen-fixing mutualist
um and cyanoase opium is more closely
related to brucella which is
um which is a pathogen of animals
um and so
it turns out that plants pathogens and
mutualists have shared mechanisms to
infect a very different hosts so uh
cyanorizobium is here infecting a bean
cell busella is here infecting a
macrophage and for virulence they both
require some shared uh conserved
ancestral mechanisms
um that are likely there to evade or
suppress host immunity
um and so confronted with the same
challenge of how do you protect yourself
from uh from microbes whether it's a
pathogen or a mutualist plants and
animals have actually convergently
evolved similar Solutions and so here
are plants they have things like
flagellin receptors that can activate
defense signaling animals have actually
convergently evolved similar pathways
um and so confronted with the same
Challenge and given uh the same
molecular toolbox plants and animals can
both sense pathogens and mutualists
um oh sorry pathogens uh non-self
amounts and immune response and so
microbes likely have evolved to
circumvent these Pathways using similar
mechanisms
um and so my lab thinks about sort of
two symbiotic continuums one is over
um actually probably evolutionary time
from Free Living to symbiotic so micro
existing from the environments have to
colonize hosts they have to actually
circumvent these very specialized
adaptations in immunity to colonize a
host and so those adaptations might
generally allow things like Priscilla or
agrobacterium to be host Associated and
then the specific adaptations might be
more recently evolved that allow a
common ancestor of brucella
agrobacterium and ceterozobium all hosts
associated
and then more recent adaptations
determine whether it's a pathogen or a
mutualist along this continuum and so
this is a model that my lab thinks about
a lot
first how do you become symbiotic
and then once you're symbiotic how do
you become a pathogen a mutualist or a
mutualist or a commensal
and so today I'm going to tell you uh
three stories from the lab
one thing I'm not going to talk about is
sort of common innovations that allow
symbiotic ancestors to become symbiotic
although that was something we're really
interested in I'm going to talk about
once you're symbiotic how bacteria can
can move along this symbiotic Continuum
of Lifestyles from pathogenic to
mutualist and so what are the mechanisms
that drive those transitions
um second does the host have any stay so
can hosts actually detect and enrich for
specific uh beneficial microbes
um and can they do so without
enriching for pathogens
and a similar question uh are hosts able
to distinguish closely related pathogens
and mutualists um in the context of the
microbiome where things like effectors
might not be playing as much of a role
um so as Maria suggested my lab uses a
rabbit office as a model for microbiome
studies and for many of the same reasons
that you all use it for immunity studies
or those of you that do use it for other
host pathogen interactions it's a great
system for forward and reverse genetics
um it's our validated reference plan so
much of what we've learned in immunity
or flowering time
um have translated to other crop plants
importantly the microbiome community of
rabidopsis at a very high taxonomic
level resembles crops and so it's it is
not a non-nodulating non-armuscular
plants but if you look at the the
microbiome composition at least the
phylum level it's very similar to our
crop plant so this is rice and corn here
um and then I always like to remember
that arabidopsis is a wild plants it's
not domesticated and so
um the natural variation and the tools
that we have in arabidopsis are
arabidopsis adopting with its local
microbiota to its local environment and
we haven't necessarily lost those
interactions during domestication as we
potentially have with some of our
foreign
so when I started working on the
microbiome and trying to ask questions
about
um sort of microbes moving a lot of this
Continuum
um I sort of took a page from all that I
learned in this departments and the
power of things like pseudomonas stringy
arabidopsis defines or pseudomonas from
use Beto to find effectors and plant
disease resistance genes and I decided
to focus just on a single microbe
associating with rapidopsis and we use
pseudomonas fluorescence and the reason
is that it's enriched in the plant
rhizosphere
um so it's really good at colonizing
plants is beneficial to plants so it can
protect them from pathogens and so we
know the outcome of that interaction
matters when it's there plants are more
disease resistant and they also uh
promote growth through a variety of
nutrient and hormone-related mechanisms
it's really interesting because its
function can't be inferred from taxonomy
so if you look at a tree of pseudomonas
and then try to predict what they're
going to be doing it actually doesn't
work and so that makes it really
interesting for these sorts of studies
and it's genetically trackable
um and then pseudomonas like the alpha
proteobacteria actually shows those
patterns of host Association and
lifestyle transitions within a single
genus and So within pseudomonas we have
originosa which are opportunistic
pathogens of actually plants and animals
there's reports of pseudomonas originosa
causing disease under very stressful
field conditions like heat waves or poor
soil quality
uh we have pseudomonas stringy which you
all know a lot about I'm sure that our
plant pathogens
and then pseudomonas fluorescens which
are described as both plant and animal
symbionts and Free Living
and So within this group uh we we study
them because first they're all hosts
Associated and um originosa is really
fun because it's both plant and animal
associated
but we consider that a lot uh today I'm
going to tell you about pseudomonas
fluorescence
um and so we wanted to understand across
this Continuum from mutualist to uh to
commensal so something that's not like
living with plants not necessarily
provide causing harm or benefit
um how quickly can those transitions
occur within this group and so we
started uh this is actually the first
Pro Stock to join the lab Ryan Melnick
um he asked within this group of
actually well-described mutualistic
pseudomonas so these are plant growth
promoters
um do they all promote growth or do some
of them uh not promote growth and can we
sort of understand the the genomic
changes that happen over these short
distances that would drive that and so
we started with our favorite
um lab model strain is wcs365 it's a
nice plant growth promoter within this
group I just want to point out for
anybody that does 16s
um sequencing these are 99 identical by
16s so these are are very very closely
related and often some of these would be
called the same ASC um so basically
indistinguishable by 16s
uh and then pseudomonas sort of species
complex would be this whole group
students fluorescence
um and so what we found that was quite
surprising was not only did not all of
these strains promote growth uh some of
them kill plants
and so
um Ryan actually one of the first
strains he tested in the lab was this
n2c3 strain which is within that
Brassica CRM group and not only did it
not promote growth it kills arabidopsis
under germ-free conditions I spent a
long time being convinced that Ryan just
didn't know how to grow plants and it
was something he was doing but when he
did this with controls of other strains
that do not kill is clearly something
unique about this strain I'll show you a
few graphs like this that are just death
Quantified so here's our n2c3 pathogen
and then these under these conditions
actually don't promote growth super well
because this is rich media but they do
cause changes in lateral root
architecture
um it turns out that n2c3 is a is a
quite broad Host range pathogen so we
tested it on this is rice and we tested
on tomatoes and poppies and whatever
people had lying around in the lab to
put in their Gardens and it basically
killed everything that we could find
um and so Ryan actually came from a
genomics background
um and as part of what he was doing in
the lab he was building a comparative
genomics pipeline to try to identify
genomic traits that would be unique to
one strain and not another and so the
idea here is that if we take
um The genome of our beneficial strains
and compare to the genomes of our
pathogen we should have most of it the
same our core pseudomonas genome but the
genes required for pathogenesis or
mutualism or commensalism should be
unique
to each of those strains
um and so he built actually a
pseudomonas pan genome um where he did
all by all comparisons and then just
generated one giant pseudomonas genome
that now we can compare each genome to
and that makes this a much easier
problem and these tools are available if
anybody is interested in the pseudomonas
ban genome
uh but when he did this we found a very
conspicuous 143 KB genomic islands that
was unique to our pseudomonas pathogen
that was inserted in otherwise a very
conserved region of the genome it turns
out it encodes stringomycin
stringopectin which you may have heard
of because it was first described in
pseudomonas ringi
um and so these are toxins that cause
disease on many plant hosts and so this
is pseudomonas stringy of bean that
causes disease in a strangomycin
strangle peptin dependent manner so
these are mutants this is the wild type
strain mutants that don't make the
toxins uh disease goes away uh here's
another pseudomonas stringy on Cherry
again this spheringomycin strangle uh
peptin mutants no longer have a
reduction in disease
um and so we deleted these in the single
in our pathogenic strain and you can see
stringomycin and stringopeptin work
synergistically to cause disease on
arabidopsis so if you delete either of
them you lose disease
um
and so that seems to be responsible for
disease but this was kind of surprising
this is a pseudomonas fluorescence not a
pseudomonas drinking and so we went back
to our pseudomonas tree and it turns out
that um within pseudomonas fluorescence
these genes actually occur quite
frequently
um and so here's pseudomonas stringy
and then these are all kind of the
pseudomonas fluorescence uh clade at
large and you can see that there's some
like pseudomonas tusco vaginae which is
known to cause race she thought that
fall within the pseudomonas fluorescence
sort of species complex and then some
are actually very closely related to our
pathogen that we found like pseudomonas
causes tomato pith necrosis are squarely
nestled in this fluorescence clean
um and so it seems that this is actually
quite widespread within pseudomonas and
is is moving around
um so we wanted to understand more about
the inheritance in this group because it
looks kind of interesting we have one
group that looks like it's got it one
group that hasn't was this kind of one
horizontal transfer acquisition event
um that was just kind of lost in a few
strains here or something more
complicated going on and so we took
advantage of the vast genomic
information available for students and
if you zoom in just on that Nebraska CRM
plan so these are all 99 identical by
16s and then this is the presence of
that syringomycin stringopupton Island
um you can see that there's been
multiple acquisition and loss events
over a very short evolutionary distance
and so there's not like there was
probably an acquisition event you know
here that resulted in all of these
strains having it but there you can't
explain this pattern here without
multiple gain and loss events and so it
seems like this island
is moving very uh being gained and lost
very readily throughout pseudomonas
lessons genomes
um and just to sort of validate that
this gene or Gene cluster indeed towards
virulence we got our hands on a number
of strains uh that have or don't have
the islands all the ones in green don't
have the island the ones in red do and
it seems to very closely correlate with
with virulence
um and so we're really intrigued by this
um this idea that maybe you could have a
lifestyle transition over you know not
the distance of agrobacterium to cyanide
rhizobium but just over you know a
single strain gaining and losing a
single Island and so we wondered is that
just it is it an island that's moving
around and causing these lifestyle
transitions or is it something more
complicated and there's a beautiful
example from Jeff Chang's lab showing
that rhodococcus through gaining a
single virulence the plasmid can
actually transition from a plant
commensal so associated with commensals
uh to um a pathogen just with acquiring
a single plasmid and so we wondered are
there other genomic changes that
correlate with lifestyle or is it just
the presence absence of this island
and so we did a genome-wide Association
where we looked for genes that
correlated with present absence of this
island and to our surprise we found
several genome-wide changes
and so this is our stringomycin strango
pepsin Island here in red and we found
two additional
um they were annotated as putative
pathogenistic Islands we still don't
know what they're doing but at least one
might be a toxin that are nearly
perfectly correlated with our
lipopeptide and then we found two
islands and a putative effector that are
nearly perfectly inversely correlated
and this is probably too small to see
but this one here is actually a Type 3
secretion Island that is almost uniquely
present in the commensal not the
pathogen
uh and then this is dapg which is a
known anti-fungal compound made by
pseudomonas that's been implicated in
suppressive soils
um and so we have uh yeah two sort of
configurations of the genome one with
this stringomycensoringopeptin and then
one with type 3 secretion and dapg
um and so we think that pseudomonas has
kind of converged on two solutions for
plants and actually fungal Association
so I didn't mention that the
stringomycin stringopeptin um
lipopeptide islands is also anti-fungal
and so one version is lipopeptides plus
these two pathogenicity islands and then
the other is Type 3 secretion plus dapg
and all strains that have these they end
up in the same genomic location and we
have evidence that they're being gained
and lost through homologous
recombination
and so it seems that pseudomonas has two
pseudomonas fluorescence has two
Lifestyles that are
um uh transitioning over very short
evolutionary distances
um
and so it seems that even within very
closely related plants
um uh Associated strains you can get
these transitions with just gain and
loss of a single Island
um so now I'm going to switch gears a
little bit
and talk about
um the sort of role of the host in this
um and so did the hosts have any say can
they specifically enrich for beneficial
microbes or even specific groups in
microbes and then as they're enriching
how do they filter out which ones are
good and bad
um
so plants do something really cool which
is that under certain stress conditions
my slides got
missing a slide okay
um
maybe I got shuffled here
so uh
plants and animals it's known that a
normal microbiome structure
is really important for host health and
so our gut if we end up with an altered
microbiome community that can make us
really sick we're associated with a more
susceptibility to autoimmune diseases
and pathogens and the same is true for
plants so the slide I'm missing you
would see that the if there's a plant
that's missing actually it's a big
component of its innate immune system
you can get disease from microbiota
um plants also do something cool where
they can specifically enrich for
beneficial microbes and so the classic
example of this is suppressive soils and
something I learned about in Plant
Pathology class there were two
mechanisms of disease resistance our
genes and suppressive soils
um suppressive soils were not well
understood but this is a phenomenon
where upon sensing a pathogen plants can
enrich for groups of microbes that can
suppress that pathogen
um this hasn't been described in animals
and it turns out it's not unique to
biotic stress plants can also do this in
response to abiotic stress and so
there's been some beautiful work from uh
from Devin colemander and the Sundries
in lab at UC Davis showing that under
drought stress plants also shift their
microbiome and so this is
drought-strapped drought stressed grass
plants you get this massive enrichment
of streptomyces and like bacteria in
suppressive soils streptomyces are
sufficient to protect against drought
stress
um and so this uh both suppressive soils
and the drought examples suggest that
under biotic or abiotic stress plants
might actually be able to dynamically
enrich for these beneficial microbes to
help protect against those stresses and
so we're really interested can plants
enrich for pseudomonas under conditions
where pseudomonas would be beneficial
and if so can they tell apart can they
enrich for just our beneficial
pseudomonas and not the pathogenic ones
um and so to get at this
um
genetic screening with microbiome has
been very difficult because microbiome
phenotypes are often hard and
labor-intensive to screen for
um and so what we've decided to do was
to take advantage of um of a mutant
collection that had been developed in
fed ossabel's lab and this is a really
unique mutant collection because it was
screened for uh root immunity phenotypes
and so these are mutants that when you
add a plant hormone that normally
suppresses root immunity so pattern
triggered immunity they're actually
insensitive to that hormone response so
the details aren't super important for
these purposes the original paper was
described here but the point is that
these mutants are specific to root
immunity mutants involved in pattern
triggered immunity
and so we had a collection of
uncharacterized mutants and we
rescreened them for ability to support
pseudomonas fastens in mono Association
and we do this by growing arabidopsis in
48 well plates and then we can add
pseudomonas fluorescence expressing gfp
and then read pseudomonas fluorescence
gfp with a Plate Reader as a proxy
versus a really easy way to quickly
quantify um
and so doing this we found that
um are mutants we found three that have
higher levels of pseudomonas and we
found three that have lower levels of
pseudomonas
and so we have pre-prints about these
two
um and I'll tell you about hsm13 today
that has more signals
um Okay so
this plant mutant hsm13 has more
pseudomonas in mono association with
just a rabbitopsis and so the first
thing that we did was to take it and
plant it in natural soil and see if it
also had more pseudomonas when there's a
Complex Community present and it does so
this is pseudomonas fluorescence gets
its name because it's fluorescence under
iron limiting conditions and so hsm13
has about 10 times more
pseudomonasaurescence per gram of root
than wild type plants and this is bulk
soil which has relatively low
pseudomonas and this is Quantified here
so this is cfu fluorescent colonies per
gram of root
um we can also do microbiome sequencing
to look at the entire community and see
if it's is it just pseudomonas that's
different or are there larger Community
changes
um and here we actually found that wild
type and the hsm-13 Newtons look quite
similar
um and so you can see this is a
principal component analysis and they
separate along this axis although that's
a smaller portion of the variation then
this axis which explains bulk soil
versus the plant genotypes but when we
look at the taxonomic levels they're
actually quite similar
um so this is phylum level
and then when we looked at individual
taxa that were different and explain the
difference we see here it was largely
limited to this family pseudomona DC and
so this is a relative abundance plot
there are some other taxes that are are
different but the most dramatic change
was actually enrichment of pseudomonas
where we have
um uh way higher in hs713.
um interestingly there's some signatures
of dysbiosis in this mutants although
it's very pseudomonas specific here and
there's much less diversity so we get a
drop in total bacterial diversity by a
number of otsus and also
um uh Shannon diversity index
um and so we wondered is this microbiome
from hsm13 is this a beneficial
Community or is this sort of a dysbiotic
community that can make plants sick
um and uh first author of this paper Yi
did a really clever microbiome
transplant experiment where he grew
either hsm13 or wild type plants in
natural soil and so he let the plant
shift the community so enrich for
whatever it's going to enrich for then
he removed the plants and put wild type
plants in both soils and then asked what
the effect of just the soil is on plant
health
um and in doing this he found that the
wild type plants and wild type soil were
much smaller than wild type plants in
the hsm-13 soil
um and you can see this correlates quite
nicely with increased pseudomonas
fluorescence so there's more pseudomonas
in these soils and so you get growth
and so it seems at least that the hsm13
microbiome isn't harmful under these
conditions although we're enriching for
pseudomonas and I'll come back to that
later because here I'm talking about
pseudomonas as one group of things
um so we were able to map HSN 13 and it
encodes ferronia kinase so
um hsm13 has a point mutation in the
kinase domain about actually
well-studied uh kinase receptor-like
kinase called fronia
um as you can see hsm13 is 4-8 which
tells you that seven other people have
found fronia out of screens and so it's
a very well studied rlk
um and I won't go into the details
because it's published but this is just
showing that it indeed is fronia
so what does fronia do it is a master
regulator of immunity and development
which is great in not great in many ways
because then you have to kind of filter
through all of the ways that fronia
could be affecting your particular
phenotype
and so it does have a role in
development
um we're able to kind of uncouple that
from our role in microbiome so I'm not
going to go into that in detail but in
immunity fronia has a few known rules so
one is that it's known to interact with
back one and fls2 which are receptors
for microbeassociated molecular patterns
um and so we thought maybe if you lose
um a pattern triggered immunity you
would get increased pseudomonas
um second it's known to be a negative
regulator of mixed two which regulates
dasmatic acid signaling which
antagonizes salicylic acid uh and so
that could also uh result in increased
pseudomonas fluorescence and then it
also regulates a basal levels of Roth in
Roots so this is reactive oxygen that's
just involved in normal growth and
development it's not your rust burst
inducible rust it's just rust that's
signaling and involved in like
cross-linking cell walls and so we
thought that that reactive oxygen
regulation could also be normally
inhibiting pseudomonas
and so we tested mutants in all of these
pathways to try to see if loss of any of
these Pathways affected Rises to your
pseudomonas and actually we found that
knocking out pattern triggered immunity
um in single mutants
does not affect rhizosphere pseudomonas
we have now tested it back one Circle
and BBC BBC back when big one Cirque one
triple mutant and you get a very slight
increase but it still doesn't explain uh
the fronia phenotype
um jasmatic acid signaling has no effect
I was actually only when we tested rbo
HD and F which are involved in reactive
oxygen production that we saw an
increase in pseudomonas um that's
starting to reach uh the level of the
fronia mutants and then this is reactive
oxygen staining so this is wild type and
then this is the ferronium mutants and
then these are the wild type infronium
mutants with pseudomonas and so again
you can see that the level of reactive
oxygen
correlates with the level of pseudomonas
and The Roots so the the green here is
more reactive oxygen and then when we
have less reactive oxygen on fronia
that's when we have more pseudomonas
and so to test if this was really the
pathway that was involved Yi over
expressed this rap2 which is Downstream
of fronia to ask if this could bypass
the need for ferronia and regulating
reactive oxygen
and so here's our parental line and then
the HSM 13 mutants and if you over
Express this rock in the hsm13 mutant
you have a dramatic reduction in the
amount of pseudomonas suggesting if you
increase the level of reactive oxygen
you can actually decrease the level of
pseudomonas
um and so that suggests that indeed it's
this pathway and not something related
to PTI that's regulating
um rise of steer pseudomos
um so interestingly
um it turns out that fungal pathogens
and nematodes can make the ligand for
feral cap um and so there's two
beautiful papers that show that
nematodes and fungal pathogens can make
Ralph peptides which are the mimics of
Ralph peptides which are the ligand for
fronia
um and so they likely do this because by
um by messing with fronia they can
actually mess with the ja pathway and
promote susceptibility to themselves so
jasmatic acid is required for resistance
to both fungal pathogens and nematodes
and so um we thought that was really
cool because this could potentially be a
way for plants to sense these fungal
pathogens and nematodes and then enrich
for pseudomonas which has been
implicated in suppressive soils and so
we asked if just adding Ralph peptides
so the ligand fornia I was sufficient to
recruit pseudomonas and we did this in a
couple ways so first we tried adding
exogenous rough peptides as you can see
there's at least 33 of them so there's a
lot um we just picked a couple that had
been implicated in um in immune
signaling and we're like the fungal
pathogens but we've got a small but
significant increase in pseudomonas
um with uh one of them or else 33 here
and this was dependent on ferronia so
you don't see the increase in the
feronium mutant and we also over
expressed one of the Ralph peptides and
you get an increase in rhizosterous
pseudomonas um just with the presence of
the ligand and so we think that
um
uh fungal and nematode pathogens may
make Ralph peptides and they do so with
the goal of inhibiting jasmonic acid
signaling and promoting susceptibility
to themselves and then plants may be
guarding this pathway
by down regulating reactive oxygen basal
reactive oxygen bubbles which in turn
results in more pseudomonas that could
protect them from these fungal pathogens
okay so
um 10 minutes sorry okay
uh okay so I've told you two stories um
one one of the uh that bacteria can
transition over short evolutionary
distances and then the plants can sort
of generally enrich for pseudomonas that
results in benefit
um these two things are kind of uh you
know even in the lab a little bit at
odds with each other right so I have
pseudomonas as one group that's all
beneficial and then pseudomonas where we
have pathogens and mutualists that are
super closely related
um and so a question that I think
naturally follows is can plants tell
these apart when they're enriching for
pseudomonas are they able to just enrich
The Beneficial ones
um and so we first asked this uh using
our ferronium mutant to ask in this
mutant are you only enriching for
beneficial pseudomonas and so here we
have uh pseudomonas commensals
pseudomonas pathogens and then
non-seudomonas
um and then in green our wild type
plants and blue are ferronium mutant
and so you can see commensals all
enriched in fronia with the exception of
um of this one which I think is super
interesting and we don't know why
but the pathogens are also enriched in
ferronia so this is pseudomonas ringi
here
um uh some of our opportunistic
pathogens like the n2c3 I told you about
and pseudomonas originosa and so it
seems like that's not it can't tell them
apart at least in this mono Association
uh that ferronia is enriching for
pathogens and mutualists
however pseudomonas are not great soil
pathogens um and so if anybody knows of
cases in the literature where
pseudomonas are roots or soil pathogens
I'd be really interested uh but it seems
that generally their leaf and stem
pathogens uh and so
uh just to sort of illustrate this on
plates if you add dc3000 to arabidopsis
Roots right not on the leaves you get
stunting of plants even with dc-3000 and
then this is our opportunistic pathogen
but if you take arabidopsis and you grow
them in natural soil and you drench the
soil with dc3000 you get no disease and
we have tried like and every time we see
a spot on the leaf it's probably that it
just kind of flashed onto the leaves
um and so that suggests that maybe
there's something about the soil
community that is
um
and so
um this is a master's project from a
student alive who asked if just in
binary interaction so if you put a
commensal in a pathogenic pseudomonas on
the same plants do you get disease or
can you protect from the pathogen and um
so this is into C3 our pathogen and
we've Nicole found that many commensals
and many that are closely related to the
pathogen so here's the pathogen on our
tree
and then this closely related commensal
if you mix them on Plants
um actually the commensal wins and so
they protect against the pathogens this
isn't true for all commensals so this is
um another clade of pseudomonas
fluorescence here and if you mix those
they actually don't protect against the
pathogen and so
um this suggests that
either some of the commensals can
out-compete with the pathogen or kill
the passion or the plants actually can
somehow enrich for just the commensals
and not the pathogen
um and so we first tried to see if there
was direct antagonism so can the
protective commensals directly kill the
pathogen or inhibit their virulence
um and so we did a bunch of in vitro
antagonism tests and we couldn't find
any evidence of direct killing
um this is also a quorum quenching assay
because our pathogen uses a quorum
dependent virulence mechanism and the
commensal can't quench the the Quorum
signal of the pathogen
um and so that starts to make us think
that maybe it's something about the
plant so either the commensal is just
more fit and growing in plant root
exudates or the plants can actually
detect the pathogen and kill it and not
the commence
um and so this is recent work that we've
just posted a preprint uh from David
Toms who's a postdoc in the lab that
just started his whole Lab at Florida
State
um and so he uh sort of asked if the
commensalem pathogen
um could if there were differences in
kinetics and vitro versus in Vivo so
again asking is it plant specific
he found that when he competed the
pathogen and commensal in vitro so our
commensalism gray the pathogen is in
blue so in vitro they always grow at the
same rate and so this is just total uh
bacterial growth in monoculture and then
pathogen and commensal
um have the same final OD and very
similar growth kinetics when competing
in culture
however in plantsa our commensal always
wins and so here's the commensal in Gray
and the pathogen in blue and so this
suggests that the competition is indeed
plant dependence and again can either be
plants immune related or just that the
commensal is better able to to colonize
plant roots
um and so David wondered
um
first decided to test could the plant
distinguish these and he used immunity
reporters so these are immune inducible
genes And the reporter lines developed
by Nico gilner's lab and so they're
nuclear localized transcriptional
reporters that are turned on in response
to mamps and Vamps primarily so
um
David asked if the commensal and
pathogen could activate these reporters
and found that only the commensal could
activate or sorry only the pathogen
could activate the reporters so that's
here with these blue dots
um so this indeed suggests that the
plant can detect or distinguish the
pathogen from the commensal
um so the next question is how could
that happen so both strains have similar
maps they're 99 identical by 16s they
actually have the same flagellin
sequence all of their peptidoglycan
biosynthesis genes look you know
indistinguishable as far as we can tell
um so it seems unlikely they could tell
them apart by Maps also our pathogen
doesn't even have a type 2 secretion
system so the effectors are not likely
candidates
and so we're really interested in in how
the plant is able to sense the pathogen
and mount this immune response
um and so uh as I mentioned if we sort
of return to our classic Paradigm of
immunity implants you have type 3
secretion where plants could recognize
the effectors or the um or the
consequences of those effectors but our
pathogen doesn't have effectors
um
they also can recognize maps and mounts
immune response but our maps are
probably very similar and so it seems
that that's unlikely I think damage is
our probably our best bet because these
are performing toxins and so they can
cause damage uh to the plant cell and
then maybe the plant could recognize
that
um so to start to get at the answer to
this um David started looking at um
at what genes were responsible for this
immune response and so now I'm showing
you instead of a transcriptional
reporter a reactive oxygen burst so
another readout for immunity
um where we have a um a die that when
oxidized so the presence of reactive
oxygen is luminescence and so you get a
peak when you get a reactive oxygen
burst and an immune response and so if
you had flagellin you get a strong
reactive oxygen burst if you add our
pathogen and commensal you actually get
a weaker but still prominent reactive
oxygen burst and then this is just our
our Baseline mock treatments
um and so David asked
um are there any plant genes in sensing
of mamps or damage that are responsible
for this reactive oxygen burst
um and so the idea that if this is a map
response like a response to flagellin if
you knock out
um uh components of PTI and so we used a
back one bkk1 Cirque one triple mutant
which is a number of co-receptors for
mamp and damp signaling
um we can see if this response goes away
and so first I'm showing you
um the commensal with the wild type or
the triple back one bkk1 Cirque 1 mutant
um and so if you add flagellin you get
this peak but then in the back once bkk1
Cirque one mutant it's down here at the
bottom the response completely goes away
um and then our commensal you get this
peak in blue and the response again like
flagellin completely went away in the
triple mutants suggesting the reactive
oxygen burst we're seeing to the
commensal is likely due to the presence
of things like flagellin or
peptidoglycan in our in our inoculation
perhaps
however when David did this with the
pathogen we saw a decrease but not a
complete loss of immune response and so
again flagellin and gray the commensal
is in red and we see a decrease in the
response in the back one uh in the BBC
triple mutant but it doesn't go down to
Baseline so that suggests a little bit
of the response is likely because of
maps and then a secondary part of the
response is independent of myths and I
wanted to highlight that the back one is
a co-receptor for a number of the damage
receptors but not all of them so it does
sort of rule out a subset of damage
responses but not damaged completely
um and so this suggests that pathogens
or plants can distinguish pathogens from
commensals they can sense the commensals
through mips and they can sense the
pathogen through a second independent
process
um so we can see that the present or the
response is Toxin dependent and so this
is again looking at gene expression now
through qpcr instead of a reporter and
if you treat plants with uh
um these are two separate reporters so
mid 51 and pr5 which are both uh
immunity PTI responsive genes
our pathogen induces a response you can
see pep one which is a damage
um Associated molecular pattern also
induces a strong response and these
responses are decreased in the
swingomycin stringopeptin mutant and so
this suggests that the plants are
detecting the um the toxin or the
consequences of the toxin the damage
from the toxin to Mountain immune
response
um and so we think that
um
for commensals in the resosphere plants
can distinguish pathogens but they may
not rely on PTI or ETI to do so because
we haven't found any role for those in
responding to our our pathogen so it
seems like they're responding to the
toxins or potentially the damage those
toxins cause to melt an immune response
um and so to sort of uh summarize what
I've told you I've shown you that small
genomic changes over a very short
evolutionary distances can result in
really dramatic lifestyle differences in
bacteria
um and that plants have mechanisms to
kind of sense their environments and
then enrich for beneficial microbes but
then we think that when you're reaching
for beneficial microbes you have a ways
need to have a way to avoid also
enriching for pathogens and so to do
that plants can potentially sense toxins
or damage causing molecules and then
hopefully you know we're thinking that
they can mount an immune response
specifically to Target those I think a
really open question there is you know
can they actually Target their immune
response to just the cells where those
pathogens would be and causing damage
um and so we are starting to think that
plants can regulate the microbiome uh
right by sensing
um uh damage or toxins rather than Maps
um and I think you know this has some
overlaps with the paradigms of immunity
that I learned in my Plant Pathology
class uh many years ago
um and uh and certainly damage and
damage responses have some overlap with
PCI but I think we really haven't
considered you know what immunity looks
like in Roots uh you know
um and given that all of these uh
members of the microbiome have similar
maps they may not have effectors I think
we need to start thinking about maybe
some some new paradigms so how is it
that plants could actually sense and
regulate uh commensals to result in a
community that's beneficial
um okay so with that I'd like to thank
the folks in the lab that um did the
work so I tried to highlight people as I
went uh the first story is the work of
Ryan Melnick a former postdoc
um the ferronia story is the work of of
You song
um another former postdoc and then
Nicole Wang and David Toms
um worked on sort of The Last Story on
the how plants can distinguish pathogens
from commensals and of course our
funding and I would be very happy to
answer any questions
yeah okay so if you if you if you find a
way to transfer the two classes from
pencils into the pathogen would you
predict the pathogen will lose
yeah I really want to do those
experiments and these islands are huge
so they've been hard to move around
um but yeah I think we would predict
just based on the genomic sequence that
that the islands are incompatible in the
same genome and so if you tried to put
them all together they'd be lost what
could be driving that I don't know
um it may just be functional redundancy
so if both the single mice and strangle
pepsin and dapg or antifungal then maybe
you just don't need both and so they're
lost over time but I don't think that's
a strong enough selection pressure to
explain the really dramatic pattern we
see and amazingly we've we've started
looking for this pattern now and we've
seen it with many other Gene clusters
and so I think the most prominent
example is with um polyamine
biosynthesis there's just small mole
molecules that are involved in signaling
in bacteria there's two Pathways for
spermidine biosynthesis that have been
described and pseudomonas all of them
have one but not both and we see gain
and loss over short distances so I think
we want to do that experiment with those
islands because they're smaller and
easier to move around and then we can
also select for them with ability to to
break down polyamines but yeah we've
gotten really interested in like what
could be driving these patterns because
it doesn't it seems too striking to just
be kind of a you know you you get one
and then you kind of lose the other over
time it seems like there needs to be
active counter selection for one of them
good
um yeah I'm really curious um
we brought with suppressive soil
phenomenon where the damage signal or a
second or some kind of pathogen being
allow for enrichment
sorry go ahead sorry so I'm I'm curious
if you've ever seen a case where a
commensal or mutualist kind of mimics
this pathogen signal especially given
the fast genomic data sets of some of
the pseudomona species if you can see
like say a Ralph mimicking protein or
something is being expressed by a
peninsula so it seems like it'd be a
huge fitness advantage and kind of like
a 2d past fashion yeah so I guess you're
asking in in maybe in just pseudomonas
or in commensal fungi uh if they make
Ralphs like peptides yeah I haven't
looked um but that's a great question
because it seems like commensal fungi
would also benefit from you know
suppressing the J pathway maybe a little
bit uh yeah that's a good question I
haven't left
um so do you think it's horizontal
transfer for these islands yeah so we
have been able so the question is
um the gain and loss of the islands is
it through horizontal Gene transfer
um and it is um and it seems like it's
horizontal Gene transfer followed by uh
homologous recombination
um and so we can see a few instances
um this is in our in the paper that uh
there's uh the island is more similar to
the island in a distantly related
species than
um you know then the rest of the genome
I guess or then sorry more closely
related to distantly related species
than to closely related strains and we
can even find examples where the island
has been lost leading behind a legion of
homologous from combination and the
inside of the genes right where it's
recombined are more similar to a
distantly related stream and then the
other Gene is more closely related to
closely related strains so we can even
see like it's happened recently enough
that we can see we can trace the
inheritance and make Gene trees of the
genes in the island and the neighboring
genes and see that they're moving around
yeah so you think it's like some sort of
Integrative conjugate development is
that like composite or is it
extracellular and it's transforming into
the bacteria we think it's just
homologous recombination so there's no
evidence of transposon or like phage or
anything else um whether it's you know
conjugation followed by homologous
combination or transformation we think
it's probably conjugation because
there's no evidence of phage uh and then
pseudomonas are just not very naturally
competence but they
um conjugate really readily so but we
can't tell how DNA is getting in but
once it's there it's about
sorry one last but have you sort of
trolled through other metagenomic
databases looking for similar islands
that might have transferred to more
distant
yeah that's a good question so um I
think David uh post office just started
his own lab is really interested in that
so
um toxins in general are so common in
bacteria and some of them are probably
for you know inter-microbial Warfare and
some of them are probably for hosts
um and there are some examples like
within bacillus of toxins moving around
over
um short distances just when we look in
the genome
um but yeah I think there's enough of
these toxins that actually could explain
some of the the differences in host
association between
this one is limited to pseudomonas
um it's a poor forming toxin so there's
many other performing toxins that work
through a similar mechanism but are not
thank you so much so good to ask one
question that came from Geneva it says
thank you for an excellent talk I'm
curious how you captured these beautiful
images of the erebalances rhizosphere
um so I think maybe do you mean the you
probably can't uh answer but maybe these
images from David on the immune
recorders
um if if so that we just have a
um it's a Flash and stereoscope
um that is actually not that expensive
um that David was able to image these
reporters on so
yeah David's a cell biologist by
training so that's a lot of that is
great well thank you very much um
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu